und es waren wieder Montagsdemos im
Osten des Landes schauen wir auf Bilder
aus Leipzig wo zahlreiche Menschen auf
die Straße gingen viele aus dem rechten
spektrumer die beispielsweise das Ende
der Russland Sanktionen fordern und
gleichzeitig verkleiden sich gegen
Demonstranten mit Halloween Kostümen und
zu zeigen dass sie die Lage in Leipzig
gruselig finden mit dem Motto Spuk auf
rechts zogen sie durch die Stadt und es
kam zu mehreren sitzblockern und auch in
Dresden sind die Menschen an diesem
Montag wieder auf die Straßen gegangen
heute kommt Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Habeck zu einem Informationsaustausch
mit der sächsischen Regierung ebenfalls
nach Dresden und da sind wir natürlich
live mit dabei unsere Kollegin Klara
Marie Becker die ist für uns vor Ort
Clara also kein einfacher Termin für
Habeck was genau sind da jetzt geplant
ja definitiv Robert Habeck wird hier
gegen 9 Uhr in Empfang genommen er ist
jetzt noch nicht angekommen wird es aber
bald tun wird dann sich in einen
Gespräch begeben mit dem sächsischen
Ministerpräsidenten Michael Kretschmer
und seinen Stellvertretern es wird über
Energiepolitik über wirtschaftliche
Themen gesprochen so vage wird es
erstmal gehalten danach folgt dann die
Kabinettssitzung an der Harbeck
ebenfalls teilnehmen wird danach eine
Pressekonferenz in der sie darüber
sprechen werden was genau besprochen
wurde und danach besucht Robert Habeck
noch ein Chemie Unternehmen hier in
Sachsen nämlich den größten Chemie
Arbeitgeber hier in Sachsen Wacker
Chemie und schon ab 13 Uhr wird hier vor
der Sächsischen Staatskanzlei eben mit
Turbulenzen gerechnet nämlich mit
Demonstranten die sich hier versammeln
wollen von 13 bis 15 Uhr und gegen
Habeck und seine Energiepolitik
demonstrieren wollen und wir waren
gestern schon auf den Montagsdemos der
hier jede Woche stattfinden tausende von
Menschen gehen auf die Straßen machen
ihren Unmut wollen ihren Unmut kundtun
und wir haben mit einigen Menschen
gesprochen weil wir natürlich wissen
wollen was sind das für Menschen die auf
die Straße gehen und welche Sorgen
treiben sie auf die Straße und wir
können direkt mal reinhören was wir uns
erzählt haben
wussten sie dass er Harbeck morgen in
Dresden
womit sind sie denn konkret unzufrieden
bezüglich der Energiepolitik ja mit dem
was er gemacht hast
dass wir Russland boykottieren und
angeblich von Russland kein Gas kriegen
dabei ist es genau umgekehrt Russland
willgas liefern aber Deutschland hat
gesagt wir nehmen kein Gas von Russland
und dann sollen wir im Winter frieren
erst einmal die ganze Masseneinwanderung
das nimmt kein Ende ja das bezahlen soll
das ist kein Platz nirgends bei mir
jetzt schlagen der landerurlaub der
Finanzminister sagt es gibt keine Kohle
mehr und die Energiekrise merken sie dir
auch persönlich also da ich jetzt im
Studentenwohnheim wohne wo wir
quasi in Fixkosten für die Energiepreise
haben eigentlich nicht so doll aber es
wurde jetzt bei uns auch schon
angekündigt dass dort die Preise ich
glaube am 36 Euro pro Monat angehoben
werden
letzten Endes schon irgendwo knapp wenn
man sagt da hat man schon immer rechnen
müssen dass man irgendwie klar kommt
man sich ja dreimal überlegen was man
kauft
sie haben gesagt sie haben Hund ja ist
zum Beispiel jetzt
zum Tierarzt gegangen jetzt muss er sich
mir selber sein bei kann ich mir nicht
leisten geht nicht
wir haben seit über 20 Jahren ein
eigenes Haus und habe bisher jedes Jahr
einmal im Jahr eine Rechnung gekriegt
für Gas Strom Wasser und so weiter und
jetzt haben wir eine vierteljährliche
Abrechnung und haben jetzt schon 180 €
fürs letzte Vierteljahr nachgezahlt wenn
sie jetzt dann habe ich etwas fragen
oder sagen könnten was würden Sie ihm
sagen
ja ich würde vielleicht darum bitten
dass er sich mal objektiv mit den
Möglichkeiten beschäftigt dir unser Land
hat durch das hinführen soll der wird
uns Mittelalter zurückzahlen Industrie
kaputt ist
da ström wird immer teurer und ihr wollt
ja eh alles machen das ist der größte
Quatsch er würde ich ihn fragen wenn in
Deutschland so sehr ankotzt warum er
dann ein Ministerposten in Deutschland
hat
ja wir haben es gehört also die einen
haben eben Angst vor der nächsten
Nebenkostenabrechnung die da eintrudeln
könnte die nächsten können der eine Mann
hat erzählt er kann mit seinem Hund
nicht zum Tierarzt gehen weil er sich
das nicht mehr leisten kann und ein
junger Student den wir getroffen haben
hat gesagt er hat Angst davor dass die
Miete demnächst im Studentenwohnheim
steigen wird also man sieht die
Energiekrise die spüren die Menschen
auch wirklich schon in ihrem Alltag
Clara Marie Becker vielen herzlichen
dank dir für diese Einordnung
[Musik]